1500 km de voirie à entretenir ensemble
durant tout l'hiver
le rapprochement entre les départements
des yvelines et des hauts-de-seine pas
son premier test neige et verglas avec
une mise en commun des moyens humains et
matériels pour assurer une circulation
optimale jusqu'à la fin de l'hiver dans
les yvelines
nous sommes habitués à des hivers
compliqué enneigées et donc on a une
organisation territoriale très très
pertinente et performante par rapport à
ça les hauts-de-seine eux ont une
organisation différente puisque c'est un
département plus petits plus ramassé
plus urbain plus de 30 saleuses 4000
tonnes de sel et 169 agents mobilisables
jusqu'en mars
les moyens sont importants pour assurer
la bonne circulation le département des
yvelines pour a notamment profité du
système si terre est développée chez son
voisin depuis 20 ans une technologie qui
permet un fonctionnement plus efficace
des feux et des carrefours
on a mis en place un réseau de capteurs
dans la chaussée qui permettent de
vérifier en permanence de le trafic
la quantité de trafic et les taux de
congestion et à partir de ces données en
fait le pcsi terre envoie vers les
automates qui cherchent pas qu'il faut
fonctionner les feux tricolores des
ordres de tendre vers pour chacun des
mouvements des temps de parcours réduits
et moins de pollution le système cité
air sera déployé dans un premier temps
dans le nord des yvelines ce dispositif
là nous sommes en train progressivement
d'étudier son extension dans les
yvelines et en particulier sur les
secteurs les plus denses comme c'est
laval en 2016 les équipes voirie des
deux départements réaliser 200
interventions préventives
la mutualisation des moyens a pour but
également de démontrer l'intérêt d'une
fusion entre les yvelines et les
hauts-de-seine
une fusion toujours suspendus aux
annonces du gouvernement sur la
métropole du grand paris